balen SCAR or at least Dave filon is
clearly a scholar of Earthling history
as ahsoka's first season has seen him
repeatedly reference quotes from real
life historical figures for example
episode 4 season pay aage to Pablo
Picasso when he proclaims that one Must
Destroy in order to create this quote
essentially paraphrases the great arist
Mantra that every Act of Creation begins
with an act of Destruction and it really
makes you wonder what balin's grand plan
is really about episode seven meanwhile
sees Balin directly quote King Louis I
14th when he tells shinh harti
that impatience for
victory will guarantee defeat given that
the 17th century French monarch enjoyed
a 72-year Reign on the throne it's safe
to say that he learned a thing or two
about playing the long game this is wise
advice to give to an ambitious Warrior
who craves power in our own right